Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
En 1965, un alumno de secundaria,
Randy Gardner, de 17 años
permaneció despierto durante 264 horas.
Pasó 11 días para saber cómo iba a
reaccionar al mantenerse despierto.
En el segundo día,
su concentración visual disminuyó.
Posteriormente perdió la capacidad
de identificar objetos a través del tacto.
En el tercer día, Gardner se volvió
agresivo y desorientado.
Al final del experimento,
tuvo dificultades para concentrarse,
problemas con la memoria a corto plazo,
era paranoico y tenía alucinaciones.
Aunque Gardner se ha recuperado
sin algún daño psicológico
o físico permanente,
para otros, el insomnio puede generar
un desequilibrio hormonal, enfermedades,
y en casos extremos, incluso la muerte.
Estamos empezando a entender
por qué necesitamos dormir,
pero ya sabemos que es vital.
Los adultos necesitan de siete
a ocho horas de sueño por la noche,
los adolescentes, cerca de 10 horas.
Nos hace falta dormir
cuando el cuerpo envía la información
de que estamos cansados al cerebro,
mientras que el entorno
señala que ya es de noche.
El aumento de productos
químicos que inducen el sueño,
como la adenosina y la melatonina,
nos ayuda tener un sueño ligero
que se hace más profundo
mientras que la respiración
y el ritmo cardíaco se ralentizan
y los músculos se relajan.
El ADN se repara durante la etapa
no-REM de este sueño
y el cuerpo recupera su energía
para el día siguiente.
En EE.UU. se estima
que el 30 % de los adultos
y el 66 % de los adolescentes
sufren regularmente de insomnio
y esto no es un hecho
de poca importancia.
Permanecer despierto puede causar
graves daños corporales.
Cuando dormimos poco,
el aprendizaje, la memoria,
el estado de ánimo y el tiempo de reacción
se ven afectados.
La falta de sueño también puede
causar inflamación, alucinaciones,
el aumento de la presión arterial
e incluso está vinculada
a la diabetes y la obesidad.
En 2014, un aficionado al fútbol murió
tras permanecer despierto
durante 48 horas
para asistir a la Copa del Mundo.
Aunque la causa de su muerte prematura
fue un ataque al corazón
los estudios indican que dormir
menos de seis horas cada noche
aumenta cuatro veces y medio el riesgo
de un accidente cerebrovascular
en comparación con los que duermen
generalmente de siete a ocho horas.
Para algunas personas que han heredado
una rara mutación genética
la falta de sueño es
una realidad cotidiana.
Esta condición, llamada
el insomnio familiar fatal,
mantiene el cuerpo en un estado
angustiante de vigilia
que le impide experimentar
el sueño tranquilo.
En el transcurso de meses o años,
el estado de la enfermedad puede agravarse
y llevar a la demencia o la muerte.
¿Cómo puede el insomnio
causar tanto sufrimiento?
Los científicos creen que la respuesta
es la acumulación de desechos
químicos en el cerebro.
Cuando estamos despiertos,
la células consumen
las fuentes de energía disponibles
que se descomponen en varios productos,
incluyendo la adenosina.
Con la acumulación de la adenosina,
aumenta la necesidad de dormir
conocida como la presión para dormir.
De hecho, la cafeína actúa bloqueando
las vías de los receptores de adenosina.
En el cerebro se generan
otros residuos químicos también
que, al no eliminarse,
sobrecargan el cerebro
y son aparentemente la causa
de los síntomas negativos del insomnio.
Entonces, ¿qué sucede
en el cerebro cuando dormimos
para evitar que esto suceda?
Los científicos han descubierto
el llamado sistema glinfático,
es decir, un mecanismo de limpieza
que elimina la acumulación
de productos de desecho
y que eso es mucho más activo
cuando dormimos.
A través del líquido cefalorraquídeo,
el sistema drena las sustancias tóxicas
que han acumulado entre las células.
Vasos linfáticos que sirven
de ruta de acceso a las células inmunes
han sido descubiertos
recientemente en el cerebro
y ellos también ayudan a limpiar
el cerebro de estos desechos diarios.
Mientras que los científicos exploran
los procesos regenerativos
de la vida nocturna,
podemos estar seguros
de que conciliar el sueño es una necesidad
si queremos mantener
nuestra salud física y mental.